the problem is is that the the invective
that was leveled from your community
towards the other communities is the
part that's ignored
[Music]
obviously a large community of thousand
researchers is going to have a big bell
curve of those who are able to play well
with others and those who don't
oh
[Music]
I mean the trouble is that they claim
it's such a beautiful Theory as far as I
can see it's a great mess I mean you've
got the wrong number of space dimensions
you've got an argument to try and argue
that you
you don't get enough energy to excite
the extra Dimension and I think that
argument is wrong actually because
the amount of energy is for the entire
universe it's not just your building
accelerator it seek get up to a certain
energy if it's beyond the level of that
accelerator that's not the point you've
got that much energy and all over the
universe things with great deal of
energy and there's no reason why these
shouldn't excite these extra Dimensions
I think there's just a misconception in
that
um I don't want to go into it further
but it's a bit technical but I think
it's a misconception and in a certain
sense there are too many theoretical
physics communities which have wasted
their time on this area rather than
doing what I regard as more interesting
topics even the question of quantum
gravity which has been brought up here
bringing quantum mechanics and
gravitational Theory together sure
that's that's a very important thing to
do but quantizing gravity in my view
okay it's an interesting exercise but
it's not the important thing in bringing
them together the important thing to get
and bring them together in my view is to
explain why quantum theory Works see
quantum theory works for tiny little
things if you like but when you do
what's called making a measurement or
you think talk about big things it
doesn't work so String Theory does not
at the moment answer the question of the
quantum measurement problem and I agree
with Roger that that's a critical
question that has faced quantum
mechanics really since its Inception so
I agree that there are open questions
that even String Theory as it's
currently formulated doesn't doesn't
address has Roger addressed it with his
approach that aspects of general
relativity will be vital to the collapse
of the wave function it's a powerful and
interesting idea I've studied it I'm not
yet convinced of it but it is among many
ideas that people were working in this
Arena have put forward I'm glad that
people are working on this key question
of quantum mechanics but in terms of the
importance of quantizing gravity I would
take a somewhat different perspective
than Rogers quantum mechanics is an
established part of the way the world
Works general relativity is an
works if they can't play together if
when you combine them you get
nonsensical results which was the state
of play before String Theory gave us a
potential solution then your physical
description of the world is
fundamentally inconsistent and I don't
think the universe is inconsistent and
therefore it is vital that we find a way
to put the pillars of our previous
understanding into harmony with one
another Eric mentioned perhaps there are
other ways of doing it fantastic I'm
open to those ideas but String Theory at
least is one approach that does that and
it's important it's vital and string
theory not only achieves it but to the
question of beauty let me just put
forward the following you do quantum
mechanics of a string without any
knowledge of general relativity and just
through the process of studying that
quantum mechanical description of a
string general relativity emerges it's
forced upon you it comes right out of
the mathematics if Einstein hadn't
discovered general relativity strength
there is studying the quantum mechanical
motion of string would have found
general relativity within the
formulation itself
that's beautiful that's breathtaking
this is really weird the post addiction
of general relativity uh let me do
general relativity for you take the
scalar curvature and integrate it
okay that rediscovers general relativity
in terms of taking the LaGrange
equations and it took under five seconds
this is not a fair way to go about
things we're now having the conversation
about beauty and ugliness a giraffe is
beautiful as is a three-year-old child
and if I cut the head off a
three-year-old child and so on the head
of a giraffe that is in some sense
beautiful in two separate ways if I take
space time and I put a collabi out
threefold uh complex threefold at every
point that has the feeling of a baby
with the head of a giraffe there's a
certain way in which it's beautiful
particularly at the level of the
analytics so what I hear Roger talking
about very often with Twisters is a much
more algebraic and geometric view what I
hear Brian talking about is beauty is
the beauty of a renormalizable spin 2
field that's massless falling out of the
quantization of a string these are
different worlds they're sewn together
in a very unconvincing and ugly way uh
we I don't want to Rob Brian of the
claim that there's Beauty because
there's tons of Beauty in the theory
there's also tons of ugliness and
artificiality in the theory as there is
in general relativity where the
equations in the lagrangian are
beautiful but the energy constrain
grants are ugly and have a different
origin are meant to keep Einstein out of
trouble so what we have is a situation
in which I feel like the audience never
actually hears a debate about the
underlying nature and we stay on the
surface level where we're talking about
it's beautiful it's ugly it post-dicks
it predicts this the real nitty-gritty
of this thing is is that Brian and Roger
are both correct and they're not coming
to loggerheads in front of an audience
for reasons that actually Escape me
I
was trying to say that all these extra
dimensions are wrong
and that's fundamental to the theory
surely that's the log ahead if I ever
thought of them isn't that a loggerhead
it's a very polite loggerhead maybe
um no I mean it's it's completely
against the way the string theory is
gone I mean
originally when I heard the idea of
string theory in the space time had the
right number of dimensions three space
and one time I thought it was a really
nice idea and it seemed to indicate that
things could be finite which would
otherwise give you divergences and so on
brings in beautiful ideas of Riemann
surfaces and Mathematics which I like
I like the idea I thought this is a
great place to go but then they decided
look it doesn't work unless you have 26
dimensions so I said okay you can work
on that I'm working on real physics
I mean
you the reason that they present that
these extra Dimensions you have to to
excite all these degrees of freedom I
think that argument is not correct to
have a theory which involves
a space which has more dimensions
the number of extra parameters is
infinite I mean it's it's not like
adding an extra parameter in the theory
if you consider the mass of the material
making up the Large Hadron Collider
there's enough energy there to excite
the w and z bosons why'd you have to
turn the machine on
to actually create them it's a question
of focusing the energy so I I I don't I
don't know why we're disagreeing on this
point but but clearly there'll be a a
message
that doesn't answer the question
what you're saying about what you're
saying about 26 Dimensions well 26 and
10 at the same time well for two
different string theories I mean no it's
the you're talking about Sonic
and you've got it's not consistent you
think you
the trouble is with string theory as I
understand it now it's not really a
proper Theory well they usually say
eventually it's not a proper Theory it's
a framework but that's a good way of
wriggling at it yeah yeah well this is
how they they avoid actually having to
put the same constraints on themselves
as they place on others and you know
even in the situation
um where you're talking about those
Dimensions because it's lorenzian it's
really two less than that so it's 24 and
8 and these are autonionic dimensions
one of three octonianic three space
generates all the large exceptionally
groups it's an extremely interesting
idea the fact that this doesn't work
is is a different argument and what
Brian is saying is true you know we
can't feel neutrinos in this space thank
God because they're tearing through all
of us body and soul but the fact of the
matter is that with sufficient care we
can find the world that is hidden I
think what what Roger's saying the way I
interpret it correct because he's right
here is how come everything that we
can't see that you keep talking about
you also have the right to place just
outside of our umvelt and therefore uh
40 years later it's not really 30 it's
39 40 years almost after the the anomaly
cancellation you've revved everybody up
we're super excited and we're left with
a practically North Korean level
Narrative of the first string Revolution
the second string then Juan found the
the equivalence between gauge Theory and
string theory and it's like we're
waiting and the problem is everybody's
revved up and people have lost interest
in other basic theories and people are
going to move off to Quantum computation
and Ai and we're going to be left with
digging out of this for 50 years why
doesn't the strain Theory Community
perhaps do something before that happens
like hold a series of conferences called
strings what went wrong were we
listening who else is out there and
bring other communities in so that we
don't lose the fundamental physics
Enterprise to Savannah hasenfelder and
her adherence to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas